il y a quelque chose de maudit dans cette terre
notre famille a
déménagé vers l'ouest sur une promesse
une promesse qui maintenant avait l'air pourrie
il n'y a plus de place pour les garçons dans cette famille
et personne n'a prévenu mon frère de ce qui
peut arriver quand on rêve du
destin c'est ainsi qu'alison wells est
entrée dans cette histoire
[Musique]
la voleuse et meurtrière allison wells a
envoyé cinq âmes humaines au paradis si vous
voyez cette femme
ne la confrontez pas
vous d'accord
quelqu'un va me payer 20 000 pour les
amener au mexique pouvez vous même imaginer la
somme d'argent que
nous avons pour obtenir tout le  les fermiers et nous
devons chercher
je dois sortir d'ici tu me chasses
tu l'
as trouvée n'est-ce pas toi la louve
c'est compliqué tu sais le pire dans la
mort c'est que le roi
est oublié
[Musique]
ce n'est pas sûr que je sois  ici
ou pour n'importe lequel d'entre nous d'ailleurs
[Musique]
je ne serai pas une autre victime de leur vie
cul effrayé ouais moi aussi
[Musique]
toi